rabid user base in their direct ipo
product do you think that had some sort
of impact here or the summer
what do you think is going on here i
think there's a lot of things that went
into this but that's the most
interesting one because when robinhood
announced they were going to open up
ipo access for their users people were
stoked like oh my gosh we finally get to
have similar footing to these large
large investing groups but suddenly if
you take away a big chunk of an early
retail demand
you really change up the supply demand
curve and i think frankly traders on
platforms like robin hood
probably were pretty active in trading
ipos in general so if they have shares
of the ipo price
it probably reduces the frenzy around
first trades and
makes it may be harder to have an
expensive pop now but jason bill
gurley's gonna love this
because all of a sudden doesn't seem to
whine about it but robin hood
probably expected a little bit more
after pricing at the bottom end of its
range
there is does seem to see be a big
disjoint be a big disconnect
between what the press is reporting
and what we as the investment community
and we have both represented here and to
a certain extent i represent both having
been a former journalist
there's this big gap between oh my god
the ipo pop
and that being the definition of success
and then what we all
experience as investors which is i
invest in the government which i think
30 million dollars so
30 million to 30 billion don't take a
genius to do the math a little bit of
dilution
this is a 500 x or one pretty great
return even with dilution because i
didn't continue investing in my pro rata
because i didn't do that back then yeah
you could have bought like another two
houses
exactly that's a good that's a costly
bit of financial conservatism
you know it's one of the things about
investing is you can learn from your
mistakes when i started i was putting 25
50k
checks into companies like this and then
just walking around we'll see in 10
years
now we just did we had two companies in
our portfolio that were raising at 300
and 600 million
we owned 10 of the company they're
raising 30 million so our pro rata is 10
a ballpark of that 30 million sure and
we actually filled
with our syndicate and our lps with spvs
special purpose vehicles those three
million dollar bets to keep our 10
ownership
in you know companies that were worth
300 and 600 million we had five to 10
ownership so we're actually maintaining
ownership at those big numbers and so
hopefully that pays off but
what do you think that disconnect is
about where on cnbc they're just like oh
my god it didn't pop and
aren't we supposed to price these things
so they don't pop what does it say that
it does pop
yeah so i talked to a lot of ceos on ipo
days so i've done
just over the years dozens of these
calls with people that are literally
sitting there in the room watching their
stock begin to trade
and i've managed to learn around the
edges how they think about pops
every ceo taking a company public wants
to see
10 to 15 gains in the first day it makes
them look really good
it gives their employees something to be
private proud about all the investors
they decide to lock in for the long term
during their road show they sold chairs
to
have a great first day it really just
like smooths butter over the entire
piece of bread and i don't mind that i
don't mind
the mechanism yeah ipos are
anachronistic to some degree given how
they're done but
the media and cable news
i would not conflict because okay
i don't watch cable news at all because
i
i don't have time to waste on that and i
would not say that
tracking the views of different cnn
anchors or cnbc anchors is the
the way to gauge media sentiment because
jim kramer is what
very loud and i don't think he's
indicative of what i do or what you used
to do
yeah i so i do think there is something
to that nuance where
if you're on tv and you have the ticker
you have something to measure
the entire point of cnbc or bloomberg
is up to the minute and if you want
something up to the minute
having a data feed that you get to feel
the pulse on makes it feel more alive
just like the score in a basketball game
absolutely
you tune in and it's on the screen it's
moving up and down so you have a score
card
it is one of the appeals but i think
there's this misconception that
this would be a failure or a win plus or
minus 10
actually to the majority of people who
own shares it doesn't actually matter
certainly it doesn't matter to me
because the way i look at this now and
i'm curious your thoughts
the putting aside any of the
trip ups that robin had with gamestop
and we could talk about those obviously
yeah
but putting that aside when you look at
the actual metrics of this it was 18
million when they filed their s1 in
terms of accounts
17.6 were active every month or
something
and then you had this incredible
revelation that now they're 22 million
so
maybe you could speak to the scope of or
the scale of this company and what you
think is possible
yeah i think if you look back to the
start of 2020
and then if you told us where we're
going to be today we would be very
confused about what changed but there
was during the pandemic an enormous boom
in savings
and investing activity amongst consumers
this drove robin hood it drove m1
finance
it drove etoro around the world the
coinbase got an enormous lift from this
even bitcoin began to trade better
people just had a lot of cash like jason
you didn't leave your house for a while
i didn't and i spent no money i went
grocery shopping once a week and i just
ate bananas
like i just saved money and so people
put that to work and so robin hood is
enjoying this enormous
boom not just in the appreciation of the
value of the stock market and crypto
trading in general but also just folks
having cash
so that's so true just as one aside
think about all the money we saved not
going on vacation or business trips
or conferences i looked at those three
and i was like for me i was doing four
speaking gigs a year
all of that's business class travel and
really great hotels all that money
just didn't actually flow during this
verizon never put me in business class i
just want to say and then they sold me
to
follow yeah i protested who owns tech
crunch now it's still verizon media
group until the apollo deal closes and
then will be owned by
it'll be called yahoo i think again
but um yeah am i correct that is a
private equity firm now owns engadget
and techcrunch
but the deal has been announced and
agreed on but hasn't get closed so we're
in that
that awkward period in which like you
you broke up with someone but you still
live in the same house
that's where we're at it just says we're
in this on this tangent
sure what does that mean in terms of
like management of your brand is there
some
are you guys just off on this island
just doing the best you can or is there
somebody like
we have to hit these numbers and there's
a sense of urgency so
techcrunch's culture this is my second
time at tc so i have two different kind
of blocks of time at the organization
the ethos of tc has been preserved
through all of the
corporate sturmundrong and so i'm
optimistic that we're going to hold on
to it again post-apollo
private equity has a reputation for a
reason so i'm not going to promise you
anything jason but today
i freaking love tc i still have the
independence and freedom and flexibility
and support and it's great frankly i'm
happy
i'm nervous because i'm being sold we'll
have to see how that shakes out
i was hoping that i made a i made a
salvo in
between the aol and verizon days okay
any chance i could shake off and gadget
or autobug and they're like yeah we
don't know
who you'd even talk to about that i'm
like okay
let's try to see if i can or even
techcrunch i was like i'll take all of
these brands don't you have uh
are they for sale and they're like we
don't know like who knows like nobody
well it turns out the whole package was
for sale and we're being sold and you'll
love this jason if we're roughly 0.5
revenue
that's our multiple it's 0.5 not 13 not
27.5
0.5 times 6.
8.4 billion run rate as of q2 verizon
media group
now yahoo and we're being sold for 5
billion that is the perfect private
equity
moment because they could split these
things up and then sell them in packages
and that's probably what will happen is
yahoo will go to somebody the techcrunch
and gadget brands will go to somebody
it's a smart move on their part
are you getting a little sick of the
cloud wars aren't we all
it's time for you to cut your cloud bill
in half
get amazing customer support and save a
hundy
a hundred dollars right now it's time
for you to grow your business on the
node
l-i-n-o-d-e if you're old school lenode
no matter what kind of business you're
running
whether it's a streaming app an
e-learning platform or
anything using machine learning you need
reliable infrastructure and
hosting the node offers simple
affordable and accessible cloud
computing solutions
why use the node instead of the
competition there's no lock-in you can
change services
as you please and pricing predictability
they don't
charge based on bandwidth usage this is
going to save you up to
50 percent from other major providers
and
they've been around for 17 years so they
know what they're doing they've been
doing this forever
we use lenod for hosting this week in
startups australia and it is
absolutely fantastic we get 24 7 human
support
with no tiers or handoffs that's why
lenode is the leading
independent public cloud provider see
if you can cut your cloud bill in half
today and save a hundred dollars
at twist lenove.comtwist l-i-n-o-d-e
dot com slash twist to create an account
and receive
that hundred dollar credit okay let's
get back to this amazing episode